I was hardly more than
a tourist when  I first went.
I just
gasped at seeing the
extraordinary main temple and
and the great abundance of
monuments and I knew nothing about those things
in those days
I've seen simply stuck to it because
I realized there's nobody else doing the
job
so
it seemed to me that I would have fun
being
a bit of a
pioneer, I suppose you could say
and dealing with all sorts of challenges
of every kind, I mean
health and
food supply and
methods of
finding guides and so it was all just a
wonderful challenge.
I of course soon realized I had to
take flash photographs
and that really meant
using
two flashes, one as a fill in and another one
at a
raking angle
but of course I was
much more able as the photographer in those
days than I was as a draftsman the
I mean even doing the drawings
I found I had to
devise various conventions of drawing
and
I soon had to realize that I  had
really to
correct the drawings at night
because
as
the sculptures were in bare relief
and nearly always
rather eroded
there would be very fine remains of
incised lines, for instance, which were
almost obliterated by erosion,
but by casting
the beam a light at a
low, at a raking angle,
you could you could you
could retrieve them
and so that became an important part of the
way I did things.
Draw them by day, do
as much as I could by day, and then go back
at night.
I really haven't changed my methods
very much
and I certainly think
I regard myself as very lucky as having stumbled
into all this.